donde nos quedamos en el último vídeo
intentábamos descubrir cuáles eran las
24 raíces de uno para que al elevar las
al cuadrado tomemos el valor absoluto de
su parte imaginaria y luego lo sumamos y
eso era esencialmente lo que teníamos
que verificar y para lograr eso pues
vamos a dibujar esas raíces entonces la
primera de ellas es es el lápiz bueno es
esencialmente es el lápiz y entre 12
entonces tomamos un ángulo de pi
doceavos que son 15 grados
aquí tenemos pi doceavos muy bien el
siguiente es ala
4 p / 24 que era la y sextos a lápiz
sextos y aquí está y sextos aquí está pi
cuartos
cuartos es otra de las raíces este será
éste era a mi tercio es claro y tercios
que es 8 entre 24 aquí está este no se
podía simplificar éste simplemente de 5
pi doceavos y bueno antes de continuar
lo que tenemos que ver es bueno
recordemos de aquí del enunciado es que
queremos sumar el valor absoluto de la
parte imaginaria del cuadrado de
nuestras raíces verdad entonces si
retomamos eso cuál sería el cuadrado de
un número complejo para para ir para ir
aterrizando ideas tenemos un número
complejo de la forma más b i y si lo
elevamos al cuadrado esto es cuadrada
más 2 ave y menos b cuadrada muy bien su
parte real sería cuadrada menos b
cuadrada más
2 ave que es su parte imaginaria por y
entonces si después de eso nosotros
queremos en las raíces elevarlas al
cuadrado digamos estas son son las
raíces verdad estos puntos y además
ahora tomamos la parte imaginaria que es
2a b 2a por b y luego le tomamos el
valor absoluto
entonces si tomamos el valor absoluto
por ejemplo si aquí tienen ustedes son
además b y digamos éstos son además b y
los que se encuentren acá son de la
forma a menos b y los que estén por acá
son de la forma menos a menos b y estos
son de la forma menos a más
b y entonces realmente no importa como
como donde los tomemos porque al final
vamos a multiplicar los y tomar el valor
absoluto entonces simplemente basta ver
qué pasa con estos y después multiplicar
por 4 verdad porque todos los demás
están distribuidos de la misma forma en
los otros
desde el círculo unitario lo único que
nos faltaría ver es bueno por supuesto
eliminamos a uno porque dijimos que uno
no lo queríamos y consideramos ahora
bien qué pasa con pi medios pero pi
medios pi medios
aquí tiene su parte real y al api medios
por y es verdad simplemente no puede
verificarlo desde la fórmula de hoy leer
pero como su parte real es cero entonces
al elevarlo al cuadrado y tomar la parte
imaginaria habría que multiplicar por
ese cero y no contribuye en nada a la
suma así que lo podemos omitir y
simplemente
lo podemos omitir
ahora también veremos que menos 1 es una
raíz verdad pero menos 1 elevado al
cuadrado es 1 y su parte imaginaria es 0
entonces tampoco contribuye nada y
tampoco este de aquí que sería menos y
medios así que sólo basta con estos 4
calcular el cuadrado de ellos luego su
parte imaginaria luego su valor absoluto
luego los sumamos y luego lo
multiplicamos por cuatro y tendremos ya
casi la respuesta muy bien entonces
vamos a empezar lo vamos a empezar lo
tenemos
a la pido o sea vos
tenemos a lápiz sextos y
tenemos a lápiz y cuartos y cuartos y el
ala peter cios y y finalmente a las 5 p
sex en cinco pisos ya 2 perdón
5 12 a vos y si los dos anoté todos bien
verdad luego estos hay que elevar los al
cuadrado hay que elevar los al cuadrado
y por eso es tan útil utilizar esta
anotación de exponenciales porque elevan
al elevado al cuadrado simplemente es
multiplicar por dos los exponentes
entonces que nos queda
al api sextos y
halabí tercios y ala y medios y ella la
pues aquí sólo nos queda a las dos
tercios y y a las cinco y sextos y muy
bien entonces pues sólo nos queda
calcular quienes son quienes la parte
imaginaria de éstos de estos números así
que vamos a verlo es más él es mucho más
fácil verlo en el círculo unitario voy a
hacer uno más
un último círculo unitario ahí lo tienen
así que quién sería pi sexto es el
ángulo pi sextos es son 30 grados verdad
entonces aquí tenemos 30 grados
sabemos que aquí tiene bueno esto el
radio es un honor y la altura es un
medio entonces aquí
en realidad estoy calculando eso porque
es la parte imaginaria de esto por la
fórmula de hoy leer es el seno de pi
sextos en este caso sería el seno de pi
tercios seno de pi medios y el seno de
dos tercios y finalmente el seno de
cinco pi sexto es muy bien simplemente
de la fórmula de hoy leer verdad esto es
ccoo senodep y sextos más veces seno de
pi sextos la parte imaginaria es seno de
pi sextos por eso es que calculó la
altura que es el seno de este ángulo muy
bien entonces el seno de pi sextos es un
medio aquí tenemos un medio cuánto es
petersen grados estos son 30 grados 30
perdón 60 grados entonces más o menos es
algo así y su altura pues es raíz de 3
entre 2 tú dirás bueno como lo obtuviste
pues simplemente utilizando el teorema
de pitágoras porque esto vale 1 se puede
ver que aquí vale un medio y pues en la
altura corresponde utilizando el teorema
de pitágoras a uno menos un cuarto y le
sacamos raíz cuadrada ok digo eso si no
puedes hacer simplemente el análisis de
los triángulos 30 a 60 90 senodep y
medios es es muy fácil porque eso es la
altura es uno seno de dos tercios
quienes dos tercios tenemos dos tercios
son dos tercios
bueno peter si son 60 grados así que dos
tercios son 120 grados eso más o menos
está por aquí de hecho ésta está a la
misma altura que cuando tenemos 60
grados verdad 60 grados
entonces es la misma altura y por lo
tanto corresponde a raíz de 3 entre 2
ahora seno de pi sextos eso también está
a la misma altura pero ahora de cuando
tenemos 30 grados o lo que de este lado
y la altura es un medio un medio así que
ahora nos toca sumarlos bueno a ver
tenemos un medio y un medio eso nos da
uno más uno nos da dos y luego tenemos
dos veces la raíz de tres entre dos así
que nos queda dos más la raíz de tres y
ya casi pero recordemos que esto debe
pasar cuatro veces verdad uno por cada
uno de estos sectores así que si ahora
multiplicamos por cuatro esto nos da
simplemente cuatro perdón cuatro por dos
son ocho más cuatro raíz de tres muy
bien y esto se parece mucho pero mucho a
lo que tenemos ya aquí verdad nos dice
que esta suma es m más en el raíz de p
que nuestro caso era 8
4 raíz de 3 y en efecto el 3 ya no se
puede simplificar verdad con esta raíz
así que ya tenemos quienes m quienes n y
quien es p ya podemos empezar a tocar el
redoble porque ya tenemos la respuesta
nosotros queremos calcular n n&p que en
nuestro caso sería 8 438 más 4 son 12 y
3 son 15 después de tres vídeos pudimos
encontrar que nuestra respuesta es 15 un
aplauso para todos